there was a really horrific apparent
hate crime
in new york just uh just came out over
the past few days
anti-asian violence is on the rise we've
been told the cause of this is white
supremacy so
you can take a take a listen to what
happened to new york
so an asian woman walking by
yeah we've blurred this too because we
don't i don't want to see this woman
getting
pounded so asian woman walking on the
street
and a black guy walks up and just kicks
her right in the face and then just
keeps kicking her in the face
there's a security guard inside the
building with the door open
so is he going to go help they're not
helping at all is he going to go out
there and help her now
no he closes the door closes the door on
her
as far as i can tell no white supremacy
present anywhere in this video as far as
i can tell no white people present
anywhere in this video
and yet we are being told i kid you not
that crimes such as this perpetrated by
one
racial minority group against another
racial minority group
are caused by white supremacy
because white supremacy is not the
conclusion of any argument the left is
making it's the premise
it's the lens through which they're
viewing the world so they'll say yeah
okay this black guy comes up and he says
to this asian woman you don't belong
here and he kicks her in the head
and he viciously beats her and these
these
i don't even want to call them men these
things standing in this this doorway not
helping her closing the door on her
they do nothing
but this is caused by white supremacy it
reminds me of this uh
uh rather christian idea that man is the
the greatest of all
beings right of all created beings
and so when man turns toward god he he
really shines right he really is the
greatest greatest of all
beings but when man turns away from god
and embraces
wrath and violence and viciousness like
the man on the street
or when he embraces cowardice and
selfishness like those men
in the building he becomes the worst of
all animals
the lowest of the created things now
that's i think what we're seeing
in this video is the issue that's going
on in this video is it white supremacy
uh no very obviously not
is it race well there's obviously a
racial component there the guy says to
the asian woman you don't belong here
so it at least seems very likely that
race plays some role
but is race even the primary issue here
i don't think so
i think the primary issue is a total
breakdown of
civil society i think the issue is a
complete breakdown of education
i suspect at issue here is a breakdown
of the family which teaches you
love loyalty and obligation to the
smallest political unit up to the larger
political unions
and i suspect what's going on here is a
breakdown of the justice system
that guy who kicked that woman in the
face apparently he's been arrested
thankfully
apparently he uh he just got out of the
clink a little while ago
he served 17 years after murdering his
mother
a guy murders his mother goes to jail
for 17 years if you murder your mother
i don't want to seem like i'm a crazy
bloodthirsty pro-capital punishment guy
if you murder your mother i don't think
you should get out of prison
i don't think you should go to prison i
think you should be executed by the
state
i don't see any exception to that rule
right is that so crazy
am i such a radical for saying that but
no because we
we now are told we need to be
compassionate we need to it's so
compassionate
and it's actually a matter of justice to
pull people out of the justice system
and let them out on the street so they
can kick asian women in the head
is that is that compassionate is that
justice i
i don't think so if you enjoyed that
break from disinformation historical
revision
and screaming about the end of the world
be sure to hit the subscribe button
so that you never miss another video